- I'm Vince Kelvin.
- I'm Chris Nappi,
I'm a dating coach and pickup artist.
- I'm known to make men less creepy.
(dramatic music)
- I understand where the
opinion's coming from
but I don't really like the language
'cause it's like objectifying
women as like a sexual object.
- I'm like disgusted.
I'm like.
(Kyion gags)
- You're not entitled
to women's attention.
- I think he is just
trying to sell a product
at the end of the day, you know.
- Holy (beep) this is crazy.
(upbeat music)
(heart beating)
- Attract and seduce more beautiful women,
learn how to approach
beautiful girls with ease
and drive them crazy with attraction.
The art of seduction is critical
to your success as a man.
Right now already what I'm seeing
is a lot of toxic masculinity.
The idea that in order
to have worth as a man,
you have to have some sort
of level of sexual conquest
and that drives from a very fragile ego.
(upbeat music)
- [Interviewer] You've been described as
"the king of make outs," is that true?
- I love making out, you know.
(upbeat music)
(Brooklyn gasps)
- Holy (beep) this is crazy.
- Okay, wow.
It's a lot of kissing.
- Vince Kelvin, the king
of make outs, hands down.
Over 230 make outs last year.
- Who's keeping track
of make outs and why?
- Like I wonder if he has
trouble feeling his emotions
and like he wants that high
of making out with girls
to feel something in his heart.
- All of those make outs seem consensual.
So there isn't much that I
can say if y'all both like it,
y'all both do your thing.
- Okay, hold it.
Your looks are distracting.
You gotta at least say hello
if you're gonna pass by
with such cool looks.
- Okay, that kind I
would've got me honestly,
I probably would've stopped, but like, no.
(Kyion laughs)
- I really mean it, genuinely.
- Thank you.
- I kinda forgot where I was going.
And what are your names?
Wait, like a civilized Hello.
Fast one though, 'cause I gotta run.
- Okay, notice these
women's body language,
they do not wanna talk to him.
It does not matter that
he is complimenting them.
They're not interested.
- So how about you just go to a place
where people are open to talk
to you in the first place?
Most people that are
walking on the sidewalk
are heading somewhere to do something
and don't have the time
to talk to some creep.
There's multiple ways to meet people,
but on the sidewalk as
somebody's heading to their job
or meeting up with a friend,
you're not going to get great results.
(dramatic music)
- We cannot meet people
on the street anymore.
What is that?
Where are we going
if we put restrictions to
where you can meet people?
Think about it.
(dramatic music)
- [Interviewer] You go ahead
and continue onto the next clip.
- Are you like a bouncer
for a club or something?
- Nah.
- It's club Melanie.
I've been wanting to come
into club Melanie forever.
You guys never let me in.
- I'm sorry.
- Today I'm coming in.
- No.
- Even if I have to use force, Melanie,
today I'm entering your club.
- Okay, first of all, if I was her,
I probably would have not
entertained all of that.
To me it was kind of obvious
that she wasn't really trying to talk.
So I feel like, you know,
you don't have to push it at that point.
Yeah, I don't like unconsensual touching.
I hate when guys touch me.
- You're not entitled
to women's attention.
- [Interviewer] Why do you think she said,
"No, thank you," so politely?
- Because a lot of women
are afraid to be aggressive
or assertive when
stating no because again,
men have a habit of kind of assaulting us
for not being polite enough.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, by the way, something
smells real good here.
What is it?
Is it your hair?
(laughing)
- Too much.
- No, it's not your hair.
It's right here.
Something that's right here.
Let me see.
- [Kyion] Too much.
(audience laughing)
- Normally, when I do that
routine then I go like,
"But rest assured,
"I won't bite you 'cause I'm
a vegetarian, not vampire."
The most I will do is this,
but I'm not gonna do it.
- I'm like disgusted, I'm like crawling.
- Don't do that.
Do not invade their personal
space without their consent.
Don't touch people without their consent.
- Like, he's making it seem like,
"Oh, this is the way you can get girls
"if you like act like me."
But she clearly looks like,
obviously like irritated.
She looks uncomfortable.
I feel bad for her, honestly,
at this moment it's.
- I like myself, I like myself,
I like myself, I like myself.
'Cause I'm sexy, 'cause I'm sexy,
'cause I'm sexy, 'cause I'm sexy.
And sexy women crave my (beep).
Sexy women crave my (beep).
- It's nice, he's like uplifting
like his male community.
I mean that's basically, I
can't really say anything else.
Like, it just seems so sleazy.
- If they do that every
morning, they feel confident,
all power to them to be honest.
- [Interviewer] Does that
one get approval from you?
- I get, yeah, approval.
Minus the, you know, that thing.
But everything else, I respect it.
- I guess, it's cool that
you're trying to help people.
I think that is very nice
and kind from the heart.
- [Interviewer] Would you be open
to meeting Vince today face to face?
- I'm good, thank you.
(Riki chuckles)
- Not really, I don't think
we'd have a ton in common.
- I'm moved, saddened,
not really surprised.
(dramatic music)
Surprise
- Surprise.
- Hello.
(Brooklyn chuckles)
Hello Vince.
- It's nice to meet you.
- Likewise, you comfortable with touch?
- Only the hands.
I think we're in the day
and age where you ask first
and yeah, the videos, they were,
it's out of context, you know?
- Yeah, 100%.
- We gotta know that it's out of context,
meaning, we don't see
what happen before.
- But I have seen
your other videos though.
- You have?
- I have, yes.
- As far as some of the dating techniques,
it's important to respect
each other as people.
And I feel like some of the things
that you were doing maybe
make people uncomfortable,
especially, as a woman,
you don't know when, you
know, if I deny this man,
if that's gonna be the man that
tries to hurt me, you know?
So it's not always easy
to just tell a guy,
"Hey, you're making me uncomfortable."
- I lived in Vegas when I was younger
and I was actually
approached by a pickup artist
and he tried to touch me as a 13 year old.
- I come from the place of making men
more aware of abundance.
A a guy is talking to
you and he does something
that makes you uncomfortable right away
because he knows there's more available.
He's good with that, so--
- Interesting logic.
- I'm making them gentlemen.
- I think it's disgusting
but if you, you know, if,
I think a lot of men and
people out there need help.
So I guess it's a good thing
that you guys are helping them
but it just gotta, you
know, not cross boundaries.
- A lot of it is due to a misconception.
A lot of people go, "Oh,
that girl is uncomfortable."
The girl at the end of the
free presentation hired me.
She became one of my top trainer.
So there's a lot of assumptions.
Assumption.
(dramatic music)
- I'm "confidencechris" on TikTok.
The reason I think I
give good dating advice
is because I know what
the toxic guy thinks
because I have been that guy.
- [Interviewer] What's
your opinion on feminists?
- You know, I like to
think I'm a feminist.
I (beep) with feminism.
- Confidence Chris, it's
not what you want to hear,
it's what you need to hear.
Okay, you can schedule a phone call
with him for an hour for $250.
(Kyion sneers)
Okay.
- All right, I know this one's gonna bad
'cause it's a podcast
and men and podcasts don't go
well together to be honest.
- As a girl, you can be
with whoever the (beep)
you wanna be, right?
There should be guys in
life that you're like,
"You know, I (beep) with you
"but realistically you are not that cool
"and I'm down to just (beep)."
I don't think you should hold back.
I honestly don't think
you should hold back
if you wanna (beep) the
guy 'cause he is hot
and he doesn't have anything
else going on for him.
- I understand where the
opinion's coming from
but I don't really like the language
'cause it's like objectifying
women as like a sexual object.
Just like I wouldn't talk
about a man like that.
- There's nothing wrong with
wanting to (beep) somebody
just because you wanna (beep) them.
You don't have to always be looking
for a relationship and that
goes for men and women.
- This is gonna sound stupid,
but kind of look at
them as if it was like,
you're just your home.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- It's just like you're talking
to somebody and it's like,
okay, like we're just having
a regular ass conversation.
- Yeah.
- Treating them as
if you've known them for
almost a really long time.
Not being afraid to just talk
to them like they're a
normal (beep) person.
You know what I mean?
That's really what it comes down to--
- A friend.
- [Chris] Yes, a friend.
- [Client] A friend.
- Look at her like she's an ugly chic.
(laughing)
- He had me until the end.
Promoting confidence in
people, that's great.
But like, talk to everybody
as if they're a friend.
They don't need to be an ugly person
to talk to them with
kindness and understanding.
Like just get to know people.
That's all you have to
do at the end of the day.
- [Interviewer] What would
you think if I told you
that most of his audience is women?
- I think, I mean, I can see why.
He's pretty, he's attractive.
- All right, let's go for
our biggest icks for girls.
It's hygiene.
- Okay, one ick I have is when
men use the word ick, okay?
That's a girl thing.
That's for the girls, I'm sorry.
Okay, continuing.
- You know, no one loves a smelly coochie.
You're not a bad bitch.
you're just a regular White
girl from a small White town.
(Vikki laughs)
- Did you really just
say, "Smelly coochie?"
- Sorry, the BBL's gotta go.
That shelf is looking a little
suss, you tell me, come on.
- Okay, I'm personally
not really for the BBLs,
but if they're making women,
if women wanna do that
and wanna look that way
then it's not really
up to like this person
or this guy to decide that it's in or out.
I mean, tribal tattoos are out
and he still has these, moving on.
- Okay, do not give away
your access for cheap.
It's giving feminist.
- You hold your access.
You really want a guy to like you a lot.
You make it (beep) hard.
- [Podcaster] Yeah.
- Think about the feeling you have
when you hike a small mountain.
You're like, "All right, I don't care."
But like, think about the
feeling you would (beep) have
if you climbed Mount Everest.
Now imagine the same thing
about the way a guy was
trying to go after you.
If you make it Mount Everest,
they're going to
appreciate you a lot more.
- I see the logic, you know,
but I think everyone is different.
It's all a case-to-case thing.
- I do not agree with that at all.
(chuckles)
I feel like this kind
of video is insidious
in its impact because
it's saying to women like,
"Oh, you know, make things harder."
But what that message sends to men is,
"Oh, it's not that she
isn't interested in me,
"that no didn't really mean no
"that no actually meant try harder."
And that's a lot more
dangerous of a narrative.
- Chris, I think you might
just be a little young
I don't know how old you are,
but I, some of these things like,
"Don't give away your access for cheap."
They just feel kind of
like you have blinders on
and you're only thinking
from your point of view
when there's like so many point of views.
- [Interviewer] Would you be
open to meeting Chris today
and talking to him?
- Sure.
- I'd give it a shot.
- Hey.
- Nice to meet you.
- What's going on?
- Hi.
- [Chris] Hey.
- How's it going?
- Chris.
- I thought you'd be taller.
- Thanks, I get that a lot.
- Yeah.
(Chris snickers)
- Hello short king.
- Oh, Jesus Christ.
- Can I give you a hug?
- Yeah, you give me a hug.
- Oh my God.
- I know you only only saw a
handful of the videos, but--
- I think I've actually
seen your stuff on TikTok.
That's why I think I was confused
'cause I've seen stuff,
like your other stuff on TikTok
that actually gave really solid advice.
- I think that's like
the issue though is that,
like a lot of people do see
these like quick things.
They make one second judgment
and then they're just
like, (beep) this guy.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- I think that's a
problem with the internet.
- Would you say that any of my videos,
I think you said one
of them was insidious.
- Not intentionally insidious,
but I do think it has the potential
to bring the wrong message
to the wrong people.
- Gotcha.
- Which is what I'm saying, like,
'cause like I don't think
you come from a bad place.
You don't--
- No.
- You don't strike me as one
of those bad dudes who's like,
"Oh, (beep) red pill."
- No.
- Like, you're not
one of those guys
- No, that's not my vibe.
- It just seems like there might be
a little bit of blinders
on in certain areas.
- That's fair, I mean,
I would agree with that.
I feel like I hear a lot of
these comments like online
but then just like hearing
it from people directly
is just a different experience.
You're like, "That's not what I intended."
I think hearing all those
different perspectives,
like, honestly, in a
weird way helps me like,
think about or make the content
I make because I'm like,
"What I'm (beep) saying is not necessarily
"what they're picking up, to be honest."
Actually no, that's my new thing
is that I'm trying to like date a girl
who's like six foot, you
know what I'm saying?
I'd be like,
"Yo, can you get that like
box of Cheerios for me?"
And like handle my business too.
I'd be like, "Yeah, that
guy is bothering me."
(Chris and Kyion chuckle)
- This guy's bothering me.
(Chris laughs)
Let me get out off here.
(Kyion laughs)